ces termes en 2010 où tu nous avais
parlé à l'époque de planet solar
on aurait montré de très belles images
ça sente l aventure ça sentait le soleil
ça ça donnait envie pour le dire en un
mot qu'est ce qui est advenu du projet
depuis maintenant d'abord merci de
m'indiquer bonsoir je très heureux
d'être ici ce soir
deux ans après ma première intervention
d'un ted c'était quand même un martini
donc c'est un bon souvenir
et puis aujourd'hui un planet solar
lorsque j'ai terminé tour du monde ça
comme un 8 oct rien sur ce projet deux
autres bateaux donc il fallait passer à
autre chose
donc aujourd'hui laventure de prensa
l'art continue sous noirs sont l'équipe
on va dire d'origine donc le bateau là
pendant deux ans il a fait des missions
scientifiques principalement pourquoi
l'université de genève
une première mission scientifique à
travers l'atlantique en année passée
reste année sont partis en grève pour
une mission archéologique
maintenant il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés le bateau cherche repreneur
ou plus intéressé donc si quelqu'un
avait un bateau solaire à vendre la
remise ou c'est un endroit sympa mais
c'est un super bateau
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter si on
être en contact avec l'appareil qui
mettra en contact avec les acheteurs est
ce que vous pouvez nous parler de votre
prochain défi donc on a une nouvelle
aventure cette fois après le tour du
monde cette fois ci c'est d'aller
côtoyer les étoiles
depuis c'est à dire la frontière de
l'espace avec un avion solaire biplace
de monter à peu près à 80 milles qui les
vingt-cinq mille mètres d'altitude
google est suffisamment haut pour voir
la courbure de la terre et voir les
étoiles en plein jour c'est avec de
l'énergie électrique et solaire
voilà donc là la grande différence avec
man solar c'est comme cela c'est un tour
du monde solaire imaginons avait déjà
fait à la voile cette fois le but
d'utiliser l'énergie solaire pour ce
record d'altitude c'est que c'est le
seul moyen à part les fusées les ballons
c'est le seul moyen de voler cette
attitude pour ce qu on est serein
propulsion électrique et solaire
plus on monte et plein d'énergie donc
vraiment utiliser les avantages de
l'énergie solaire pour faire ce record
qui serait une aventure incroyable alors
falloir concevoir une combinaison
d'astronaute solaire n'a jamais été fait
auparavant
incroyable et un observateur très
attentif de tout ce qui se passe autour
du solaire depuis deux ans depuis
certainement bien plus longtemps comment
est ce que tu vois l'évolution des
choses
je dirais qu'on a commencé l'aventuré
solar c'était il ya dix ans à quelques
jours près à l'époque d'ailleurs
j'habitais tout près d'ici l'invité à ta
saunier en tout de suite lorsque j'ai eu
cette idée de la saison du monde et il
ya dix ans on est on nous prenait pour
des fous cdh et écolo il et puis on
pensait que on était complètement cinglé
et que ce qu'on imaginait c'était tout
simplement impossible
or aujourd'hui et je ressens vraiment
changé il ya en suisse 100 fois plus
d'installations solaires qu'à l'époque
en disant ça vraiment vraiment changé et
aussi la prise de conscience des
problèmes environnementaux qui ont ainsi
sur terre ça vraiment marche très très
optimiste les choses changent
va-t-elle pas assez vite mais les choses
vont changer très vite
et ce genre de projet a encore sa raison
d'être justement pour sensibiliser les
gens à l'importance de l'énergie aux
défis environnementaux mon nom je dirais
qu'on a il y avait deux buts avec avec
talent cela reste un peu la même chose
avec soir stratos la première chose
qu'on veut cerner de l'optimisme est ce
qu'en fin de compte il ya beaucoup
d'organisations qui lance ahmed alarme
mais on parlait des problèmes c'est bien
mais il faut parler des solutions et
avec nos projets ce qu'on essaie de
faire
on est des écologistes on va dire
utilitariste optimiste on essaie de
montrer qu'il ya bien des problèmes mais
surtout qu'à des solutions et que si on
veut changer mais nous restons
optimistes et la deuxième et sachez que
c'est pâques ont trait à l'économie
peut-être que didier ces énergies
renouvelables c'est quelque chose qui
peut être favorable pour notre économie
également alors dans le public on a une
autre écologiste utilitariste optimiste
si j'ose le mot gérad interest a
triomphé 6 le plaisir de sa présence qui
était aussi là dans la première édition
de cette aide
et si même avoir signé en 2012 et tu me
lis ces avancées ici vous êtes
rencontrés et maintenant elle a rejoint
dans cette nouvelle aventure
il faut pas dire que l écolo parce que
première chose qui m'a quasiment au
lycée qu'elle n'aime pas les écolos ier
donc effectivement j'avais donc jamais
rencontré j'ai rencontré pour la
première fois
en 2012 lors du ted et puis lorsqu'on a
eu l'idée de faire ce projet pour la
partie sécurité on s'est dit que c'était
sûrement la meilleure personne pour nous
préparer s'il fallait sortir rapidement
d'asseoir stratos surtout ce menu à 15
mètres d'altitude donc on a pensé que
gérard dine était la meilleure personne
est en amont mais que c'était un projet
un peu écolo elle a accepté
je le remercie infiniment donc la
république va croire contacté pour qu'il
nous raconte que ses hôtes et l'ex oua
rencontre des gens que c'est sympathique
puis qu'on veut faire un exemple
c'était vraiment le hasard à l'époque
que vous rencontriez ici et que projets
naissent avec vous deux comme
collaborateur de l'accord mais moi
j'aime beaucoup cette citation de
bertrand piccard qui a dit la dinepa
fait de hasard mais deux rencontres
et puis c'est vrai c'est vraiment ici
que j'ai rencontré rendu pour la
première fois laurent ruquier ou tout
événement c'est pas tout de suite que
que les rentrées dans le projet il a
fait bien sûr d'autres étapes mais c'est
ici que j'ai rencontrés pour la première
fois puis que l' aventure tout cas pour
géraldine savary stratos a commencé
enfin merci d'être venu nous donner un
petit feedback sur l'état actuel de tes
projets de ces défis c'était vraiment
aussi le sens un peu cette intervention
d'accueillir des anciens piqué qu'on a
fait ici on va certainement continuer à
le faire dans le futur
l'année prochaine avait invité des gens
qui étaient là en 2012 et en 2013 ou
cette année en 2014 pour vous permettre
aussi de savoir en cours est-ce que les
gens sont devenus comment ça ça continue
leur aventure merci encore d'être venu
merci beaucoup et ça tout le monde